okay so suffice it to say finally we
learn that we're gonna get a
refrigerator it's gonna come it's gonna
come nine days after it was initially
supposed to be there whatever but fine
like you know what fine it's just it's
not like we needed it right away it's
just a refrigerator and this morning i
was literally on a call with you guys we
were getting ready to do exactly what
we're doing right now and my phone
starts ringing is the delivery guys and
i pick it up and he's like we'll be
there in 10 minutes and i'm like why did
the system tell me 11 to 3 then and he's
like i don't know sir we're on our way
and i'm like this is incredibly
inconvenient can you come at the time
that you're scheduled and he was like
nope we're on our way
and i literally to you guys i was like
okay i gotta go i guess we'll do this
later right okay bye
schedules are for nerds
so that's how it starts and they show up
there and i'm like okay so we already
tried to deliver this you guys can't
come in through the front there's a door
that it won't fit through so you kind of
have to go around back i'll show you and
he's like what do you mean we can't come
in through the front and i'm like
i mean we've we've been here i'm just
saving you some time it won't fit and
he's like no now let me measure it
fine but also like [ __ ] you like god
damn
so he comes in and he looks and he
measures the little door into the
kitchen he looks at me easily like oh
yeah it's definitely not going to fit
through here and i look at him i'm like
aha do you want to see the side yard and
so we have a fridge in there and it
already has a water line because it has
an ice maker there's supposed to be some
kind of shut off these guys cannot find
the shut off to the water line
and he looks at me and he's like there
should be a shut off you should know
where that is i'm like bro i just
[ __ ] bought this house can you call
the previous homeowner again let me call
her up we're buddies i bought our house
and now we get dinner every two weeks
obviously
god so he just unhooks the water and the
water is just like
sprayed and he just kicks the line real
quick like he unhooks it and he holds it
up to me and is like i'm gonna need you
to hold this so he can finish and i'm
like you know what fine do this get that
[ __ ] thing out of here bring the
other one in here let's do this and so
i'm standing in my own kitchen holding a
water line there's a front window in the
kitchen so i can see they bring the old
one out i see them go out to the front
where their truck is and then i see them
with the new refrigerator and they bring
it around and so i know they're like on
the way and i'm just standing there and
i just hear from the backyard like
perching whoosh
and then one guy goes oh [ __ ]
and they just start rushing around and i
just i walk out there and there's
water is erupting up out of the ground
like a geyser has started gushing i
don't know what has happened apparently
what genius number two did is they had
the fridge on a dolly and there was a
bush and apparently just [ __ ] destroy
this bush but also inside this bush is a
pvc pipe coming out of the ground that's
part of like the irrigation system what
he did was he dragged the fridge right
through the bush and snapped off the
[ __ ] pvc pipe and what they were
doing is one of them wasn't standing
there staring like thinking and the
other one had the broken off pvc pipe it
was trying to like jam it back on like
it was just gonna slip right back on
and like they looked over at me
and were like apparently the guy who was
standing there watching is the one who
did it and he looked at me and he was
like i can't believe that pipe was in
there it was hidden in there and i just
it's an accident you know and like it's
not like it's a little flower or
something you could like push it over
and scoot it's a big [ __ ] bush to get
the thing through where he got it
through he literally had to pull it up
to that gap and it stopped and he was
like ooh this bush is in the way and he
was just like no it's not let's go
[Laughter]
what led them to that action
but there's no version of that that's
not so [ __ ] stupid that it makes me
unbelievably angry
finally i'm like we need to shut the
water off to the house the guy who
seemed to be in charge of this was like
right right right the water main and he
handed me the pipe and was like hold
this on there
and i'm standing here
this doesn't seem like how you install a
fridge
[Music]